[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is the show where we talk about
your relationships your job
your boundaries your family yeah the
crazy ones yeah we talk about your money
yeah we talk about you right in front of
you george campbell ramsey personality
host of the ramsey network's fine print
podcast a very popular podcast where
george explores the fine print is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple a eight two
five five
two two five david's in providence rhode
island hi david welcome to the ramsay
show
dave how are you george how are you
great man what's up
all right dave so i've called and called
into a couple of times um last time i
called i forgot to ask you a very
important question my wife and i we sold
our vacation condo
and we made a lot of money off of it
we used a little bit of the money to put
door uh to put towards my dead snowball
most of my debt snowball is business
related debt
and currently i have um
i have about 68 000 left in debt that i
have to pay off and
we have uh 75 000 uh left over from what
we made from the condo purchase and
i'm just wondering if i'm better off
taking some of that money and knocking
out the rest of
my well basically almost the rest of my
debt snowball or
i have a commercial piece of property
that
if i take the money and i put it on the
commercial piece of property which would
completely pay off the property and i
generate about six thousand dollars uh a
month worth of rental income
i i want to put it towards the building
but i'm not sure
following your steps
as to uh
what you should do yeah i would not just
pay off my debt you work on your
building later it's a baby step six item
to work on the building the other stuff
baby step two
so yeah let's go ahead and knock it out
and the reason is this whether it's
business related debt or not you sign
for it personally it's all personal debt
correct and so it's um
the law doesn't call it business related
debt the law calls it david in rhode
island's debt
and so yeah i would just i'd be clear of
that and and
and then take your income which you've
got a great income obviously uh and
let's begin to attack that commercial
building and and your home if you
haven't paid off your home as well yeah
and a good reminder david when you clear
that 68 000 in debt you're going to free
up a lot of payments which is going to
give you more ammo to pay off this
commercial property even faster
yeah yeah i doubt you'll free up 6 000
worth of payments which you said you
would have done on the commercial
property but i don't think your payment
on the commercial property six thousand
dollars either i think that's just the
income that you're talking about there
which you still got that income and
probably have a six or seven hundred
dollar payment on that mortgage yeah so
you're probably gonna free up thousand
to two thousand dollars a month by doing
this and um you know reach over then and
continue on down the baby steps make
sure you've got your emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses uh and
start putting 15 away of your income
into retirement
and start your kids college and then
let's attack real estate debt home debt
commercial building debt
have baby step six alex is in
minneapolis hey alex welcome to the
ramsey show
thank you dan
what's up
my question is
i'm in baby step four and baby step six
uh no kids um
single with no kids
and
like to get out of baby step three two
and three i took two part-time jobs in
addition to my full-time job and my
question is how do i start to transition
from
being in the gazelle tense mode to
adjusting to baby step four and baby
step six
well we we say you go from gazelle
intense to intention null and so there's
the difference when you hit four and six
and you know me and my wife we were a
little bit intense uh in six because we
just wanted to pay off our house but
this is kind of a choose your own
adventure at this point as long as
you're investing 15
i still want you to have a goal
to as to how you're going to pay off
this house faster than 30 years faster
than 15 years but once you have that
goal in mind and you're sticking to that
i want you to enjoy your life too i
don't want you calling in going man
we've been in gazelle intense for 20
years and we don't even know how to
spend money we don't know how to give
we're just socking away money so i think
you need to set a goal still but you
also need to enjoy yourself and not be
working three extra jobs exactly you go
from sprinting to marathon and i would
drop the jobs unless you're just loving
them and they're taking you somewhere
from a career standpoint you know you're
following a ken coleman process of some
kind but if they were just for money to
get out of debt and they represent
gazelle intensity not intentionality
then um you know if you love one of them
or it's taking you somewhere i'd keep
one of them but i wouldn't keep both of
them yeah um and you know again again
there's
just being very careful and very
intentional say to six times but i mean
that's that's the thing you go from
sprinting to marathon
i like still having a goal in mind
absolutely
even when do i want to become a baby
steps millionaire when could that happen
when could i pay off the house how much
more could i give always having a goal
is going to keep you motivated and it's
when you lose all of that you just start
to get a little fat a little lazy well
in in business what we do is we call it
you need a desired future henry cloud
talks about that you need a desired
future that's your goal and then you
start immediately asking yourself what
has to be true
to get there well i gotta save 622 a
month okay that's what must be true now
you but you wouldn't have known that if
you didn't set the goal yes you would
have been going i saved money you don't
have i don't have a detailed thing so
you need to hit it and hit go okay i'm
gonna knock this house out okay good
what's that mean okay
i i think i can pay x number of dollars
and that's going to pay it off in 8.7
years okay now we got to go you know and
the x number of dollars now becomes the
the rhythm yeah and that's what you're
looking for so and you can allocate you
know in baby step four and six you start
to look at your budget and go hey let's
put some more fun money in there we've
earned it let's go on a nice trip let's
have a vacation sinking fund and upgrade
the car so i want you to have goals in
other areas of life other than just
investing and paying off the house but
but always have enough that
uh
the spending does not take up all of the
ability to do baby steps four and six
you got you can't you can't use it all
up in consumption there but um there's a
middle ground most people don't have
that problem yeah mary jo is with us in
tampa florida hi mayor joe welcome to
the ramsay show
how are y'all doing to us this afternoon
better than we deserve what's up in your
world
well it's kind of like a tricky question
um we have two kids all grown up college
everything taken care of we've worked
pretty hard we're now reaching both me
my husband we're going to be 57 this
year
and we want to retire you know five
years from now we don't want to keep
working until we turn 67 which is the
full retirement you know um so now that
both kids are out of college you know we
got them outdoors six months ago the
last one's out you know we're like this
this is time for us so we said you know
with this extra money we've been
supporting kids
let's pay off our house agreed so
currently we were looking at our
interest rate and sadly you know we
couldn't concentrate on us for so long
our interest rate is at four point six
two five oh time time
yeah i mean how much is your balance
uh well the side price we had to do a
modification about ten years close to
what's the balance the balance as of
today is 154 000. what's your household
income
how close income between us two is 115
115. okay if you're not going to pay it
off within three years you need to look
at refinancing it you might be paying it
off in three years though
so you need to lean into that and look
at it if you're gonna pay it off that
fast you may not be it may not be
profitable to refinance it but if it's
gonna take longer than three years go
ahead and refinance
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 dollars a year go
to puretalk.com and choose the
affordable plan that's right for you
with their 30-day risk-free guarantee
you have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
[Music]
[Applause]
over the last 30 years i've walked with
tens of thousands of people and their
families to help them overcome financial
stress
and of course we found money stress is
just one
of all kinds of ways we all have stress
we have anxiety loneliness all at the
same time right uh some sort of crazy in
your family somebody told lies about you
some that we're well-meaning people some
not so well-meaning people out there the
list of hurts it can go on and on
unfortunately you can't change your past
but you can change your future
here's the good news dr john deloney
ramsey personality has written a new
book it comes out in april and it's on
pre-sale right now called own your past
change your future
and he'll walk you through the not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness
through his personal stories decades of
experience and research dr daloni shows
you how to transform hurt
into healing
move from hopelessness
to hope fullness
and the books available for pre-order
right now own your past change your
future we'll teach you how to deal with
different kinds of trauma get connected
to a community
actually make friends as an adult
and the steps you take to change your
thoughts and your actions and yes all of
this is possible
all kinds of bonus items if you buy it
while it's in pre-sale including the
audiobook the
uh e-book and a month of free one-on-one
therapy with better help all of this
when you buy a 20 book
uh that's a deal that's hundreds of
dollars worth of stuff there and uh own
your past to change your future at
ramseysolutions.com our question of the
day comes from blinds.com find out for
yourself why blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey that's the magic word and you'll
get the best deal today's question comes
from john in british columbia he said my
wife and i have three and a half years
of car payments ahead of us and our
monthly payment is 300 bucks we've got
two kids earn about 45 000 a year after
taxes and our budget is fairly tight
with no wiggle room we have roughly 20k
and a tfsa and oh 15k on the car you say
to use any non-retirement investments to
pay off debt but why should we use the
20k we saved which is making 10 interest
a year to pay off a payment which has
zero percent interest i don't see the
benefit of doing that especially since
it would leave us with almost no savings
interesting
not the first time we've heard this uh
this scenario dave
i could put my money in the market and
make way more than my debt is costing me
an interest
yeah
i mean here's the thing
um
you make 45 000 a year
you have a 300 car payment is causing
you stress
your best thinking has gotten you to
this point
so you're going to keep using your best
thinking
i have to ask myself those same
questions i mean
it's like you know i hired a personal
trainer one time to come to our house
and have a little gym in the bottom of
the house and sharon's making fun of me
you're paying somebody to help you count
to ten one two three you know and i'm
like it's not what it is and she says
well you don't listen to him you don't
do what he says he's got a six-pack you
got a keg i mean you ought to listen to
the guy
my best thinking got me a keg his best
thinking got him a secret are you going
to listen to him so who are you going to
listen to your your best thinking or
someone else's yeah that's that's at the
core of this
and that's not because i'm offended that
you didn't just jump on this but you
know one of the things we have to do in
this
process is
uh go
my way's not working anyway i mean if
you keep making a cake over and over
again and you want chocolate cake and it
keeps turning out vanilla you need to
change the recipe yeah
doing the same thing over and over again
expecting a different result is the
definition of insanity so that's at the
core of this
and then we can answer the question too
yes but then that foundation needs to be
there and what's happening here is i
love math as much as the next guy but if
you just do math you go wow this works
man i'm gonna invest all the money in
the market and leverage all the debt i
can
but math is only part of the equation we
got to talk about behavior we have to
talk about risk we've got to talk about
options and freedom which he doesn't
have right now because he has a car
payment
and so if you want to have that freedom
you've got to make a sacrifice here yeah
based on your theory john you would
borrow 300 000 on a car at zero percent
and put it all in the market at 10
and obviously when i say that out loud
you hear the absurdity of it and that's
how absurd your overall question sounds
actually
so um and the reason is you've left out
risk you've left out cash flow you've
left out peace
and so what i want you to do you can do
whatever you want to do but what we
would teach you to do is pay off your
car today
or sell it
if you're going to keep it if you're not
going to keep i mean if you don't want
you want to keep the money that's fine
sell the car
uh but but i'd pay it off today if i'm
going to keep it and then i would
continue to move through the baby steps
which puts you if that makes you debt
free then you're going to move towards
your emergency fund i'm building that up
and then you're gonna move towards
retirement accounts which it looks like
he'd have about five thousand left over
even after paying off the car so it'll
get him some headway into baby step
three so i'm not sure in british
columbia what a tfsa is i'm assuming the
way he asks the question that it is not
retirement account yeah um and so but um
but conceptually if it's not a
retirement account i'm pulling the money
and paying the car off where i'm selling
the car you need to get rid of your car
payment john
um
because it's but the other thing you got
to really think about is
my best thinking brought me here number
one that's not working number two um
you you have to ask yourself if the
information i'm getting somewhere else
is credible and if it is credible i'm
going to submit myself
to that new way of thinking
and so um
you know it can be just simply uh i was
reading a book on parenting when the
kids were little
and it said this this and this this and
i went i have never done that i've never
even thought about that and i thought
yeah but the source the author was
somebody i believed in
and i thought you know what he probably
knows more about it no no
so i'm gonna start doing that do it his
way you know after reading about 15 of
those books the kids turned out none of
them live in my basement so there you go
and so it means i'm a success right so
there you go
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five for you basement
dwellers you have to know uh that um
an eagle who fails to launch is
eventually known as a turkey
i like that one i don't know if i've
heard that that's where you go so
set the little eglets free it's good for
them the little wings will develop and
turkeys get shot we will have society
and um yeah and we eat them at
thanksgiving yeah so they're oh that's
gross but okay
that metaphor unfolded poorly dylan is
with us in gainesville florida hey dylan
what's up
great how are you doing today dave
better than i deserve how can i help
well i got a couple big life changes
coming up i'm graduating college this
may with a degree in computer science
and i have a job offer in florida for
after i graduate
however
my girlfriend wants to sort of live
abroad for a bit before settling down
and another thing that might help with
context is i received a half a million
dollar
inheritance from my grandparents so i
have a little bit of flexibility but i
was just wondering what advice you have
so you're trying to figure out how to
talk to your girlfriend about this that
you don't want to move overseas
i'm interested in moving overseas
however i'm just scared about i enjoy
the safety of staying in uh you know
having a job offer i was just wondering
well if it's your girlfriend it's one
thing if it's your fiance or your wife
it's another
okay girlfriends you just send them
overseas it's fine
fiances and wives we don't want to be
separated from
am i wrong
i mean if she wants to go over there and
live that's fine she just puts at risk
the fact that you might find somebody
else while you're hanging out there in
florida i mean that's how that works
um
but i'm not readjusting my life
plan for a girlfriend
i wouldn't if i were you anyway i'm
certainly not i don't i have one
girlfriend i've had the same one for 40
years as my wife so but uh i'll adjust
my life for her
uh because she's my wife but i'm not a
just i would not suggest there's a
better way of doing a young person or an
old person adjust their life for someone
that you are not committed to long-term
you're making long-term decisions with a
short-term person
okay and if i have long-term commitments
then that might change things i guess
this is sort of like the deciding point
uh
yeah i don't know i don't know if you
guys call it how old are you
21. yeah i don't know if you guys call
it this anymore but when my kids were
like teenagers they call it the define
the relationship oh yeah conversation
that's the thing yeah and i that was
that was new to me even then i was old
so but um
it's definitely new to me now but that
that's kind of what we're having here is
you know
um
you know the only way i'm going over
there is if we are going over there
and if you break up when you're overseas
that's awkward yeah
that could happen all for a fax card
yeah there you go
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net and get one thousand to
twenty five hundred dollars off of your
tuition again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today alex and sarah are in
saint cloud minnesota to do a debt-free
scream it says on my screen hey guys
congratulations
thank you very much dave and george
welcome welcome how much have you paid
off we paid off 48 000 of student loan
debt in four months good wow
and your range of income during that
time uh we made 150 000 household
okay so you had some money in savings
you just threw at it or what yeah well
we were blessed initially by my wife's
grandma she gave us or ten thousand
dollars as
you know schooling to help pay that off
as well as we actually had 12 000 of the
student loans
sitting in a bank account that we were
going to use we're like hey we can just
pay that back to the student loans
and you know help speed this up
as well as i had a decent year in sales
so we had some money sitting around to
just throw at it okay so how much did
you
lay in a round and then you cash flowed
the rest yeah we cash flowed the rest no
we had about maybe
um i had about 10 to 20 000 in
commission sitting around okay so you
had like 35 of the 48 and then you just
plowed through the rest in four months
yep way to go man yeah what was the
wake-up call what got you moving well
our dave story starts off of we uh when
we moved up here kind of took over a
business
and ended up with going into bankruptcy
because of that business
and went through fpu actually during the
bankruptcy
and then from there
that kind of got our budding gear and
you know we were tired wow wow okay cool
good for you yeah it was so it was after
the bankruptcy you said i'm never going
to be here again yes basically
we
we had a dave's moment yeah i got i got
to learn how to say never again and what
that process looks like exactly yeah it
was it was not fun so you roll into
financial peace university and you're
looking at this you're going i think we
can do this if we just pull all these
different accounts together throw it at
it and then and then jump on it for a
few months we'll knock it out oh yeah
nope yeah we
starting with a financial piece our you
know
leader stacy she was just kind of
walking us through everything and it was
like hey we
you know looking at the money we had in
the accounts it's like hey we can just
throw all this money at this and you
know not have any payments here in the
future because another big motivator was
we didn't want to pay any interest on it
so it was just sitting there you know
interest-free because of the government
and
we didn't want to pay any interest when
it started back up what do you all do
for a living now um i'm in sales and my
wife actually just took a job as a
lifestyle consultant okay cool what does
that entail what's a lifestyle console
i'm wondering if i need one i'm a
lifestyle consultant you're spending too
much
so i work at a weight loss clinic oh
okay yeah very cool that's a good that's
a good way of saying that i like that
life it makes me feel better about it
very cool so what kind of sacrifices
were you guys making i mean you were
just gun hoe you're ready to get this
thing out of your life
yeah no we were i mean
basically our our beans and rice story
went uh consisted of running to costco
and buying straight beans and rice in
the 50 pound bags wow you took it very
literally
we were committed
for four whole months yeah for four
months
that's awesome
good for you how does it feel to be free
always feels great feels great i mean
the big news is you have a new way of
looking at things after all you've been
through
oh yeah and it has now proven itself out
very quickly for you so now you've got
to live it
yes we had a wake-up call instantly and
yeah just the mind shift that happens
even through financial peace is
is unreal yeah
way to go you guys we're proud of you
excellent
excellent
job good good work
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you how ordinary people build
extraordinary wealth how you can too
that's the next chapter in your story we
want you to play all the way through now
and finish this and do it right and i
end up with some wealth and be in a
position to be just crazy outrageously
wonderfully generous also got a copy of
the total money makeover for you and uh
that's a book you can give away and help
somebody else get on this same journey
that you're on so way to go you guys who
was cheering you on um our biggest
cheerleaders was actually that our fpu
group
um stacy was awesome uh via eagle brook
church up here oh yeah
they were people
yeah that's an incredible church they do
a great job oh yeah yeah very cool good
good well way to go you guys well thank
you for calling in and sharing your
story you're inspiring well done
appreciate it very much alex and sarah
in minnesota
48 000 paid off in four months after
they gathered the accounts together and
then finished it with some beans and
rice make it 150 a year count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one we're dead free
[Applause]
way to go you guys
blake is in idaho falls idaho hey blake
what's up
hi how's it going dude great man how can
we help
so i got a question so i'm currently an
apprentice over at a ford dealership
i got a job offer over and uh becoming
an hvac apprentice my dad talked to me
again in that i'm currently making 12.50
an hour i'll be bumped up to 12 uh 16.50
an hour but i'll be happy to go to
school in the fall two nights a week and
that's 850.
the thing is too is i have a bunch of
tool to have about a thousand dollars in
total debt and then a thousand dollars
of debt on a motorcycle i bought we did
that last
spring so i'm right now in the pitch i'm
like i don't know if i want to take this
job offer and then have more school
loans to have or what
okay i i got lost somewhere
you're currently doing hvac
uh no i'm currently an apprentice as a
over at a ford dealership right now
apprenticing for what
as a mechanic as a mechanic and that's
where the tool debt came from
yeah and then the opportunity to move
into hvac tech requires you to go to get
some vote classes is that what you're
saying
yeah and that's working for your father
uh no my father was the one that told me
about getting into hvac and that's what
i'm trying to pursue right now and get
out of the mechanic industry okay
but you're gonna have to pay for these
classes and you don't have the money to
pay for them
yeah my dad said he would help me out
pay for all of it i'll just pay him back
later down the road from what you told
me no we don't go in debt and we don't
go into dad for sure
bad plan how old are you
i'm 20. okay
why are you doing any of this
i'm trying to get a trade job
why i don't want like a normal just
office job or anything so
you like working with your hands is that
what you're saying
yeah yeah i'm a hands-on type guy that's
good
okay
what i don't want you to do is i don't
want you to invest heavily with your
time your life your education
into something just because it sounds
like it might be a good idea to make
some money
and that's what this sounds like i've
been
yeah i've done a bunch of research now
i'm watching youtube videos on it looks
like something i could get into because
mechanic now
it doesn't seem like it's really for me
why
it's
pretty much the same thing every day i'm
spending all this money each week on new
tools for a special job and they're just
repetitive
dude
heating and air is repetitive
it's only a couple of times only a
couple things you can do there
yeah i'm not spending all this money
each week on these tools though
okay but that that's not the question
you don't have to keep spending money on
tools to be a mechanic that's just
something you got sucked into it sounds
like you got a real good tool salesman
stopping by the shop to me but um
the uh uh
but but both of these are repetitive
that's true
yeah we just don't want you to go
through down this hvac path and you go
man i got to buy new tools and this is
really repetitive and i've got to do
something else now after spending all
this money
so i think you've got to take a
breath and figure out what you really
want to do and i'm happy to send you a
copy of ken coleman's book from paycheck
to purpose and i'll also get you the get
clear assessment that he has because i
think right now you just need some
vision for your life i think you need to
take that assessment and really start
asking yourself because i i'll tell you
what i am sure of out of this
conversation after talking to you for
just a minute
i think you're probably uh not only like
working with your hands you're probably
gifted
at things mechanical
it gives you joy to make things work
and you probably need to pursue
something in this field
but i'm not sure you selected
hvac any more carefully than you
selected mechanicing
i think you just saw something different
and you're tired of that one
so
i want you to take those things and then
you decide what you're going to do and
make sure you cash flow whatever
education you pursue you're going to pay
cash for it no debt or don't do it
just don't do it if you have to go in
debt even to your dad
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is
our co-host today thank you for joining
us here on the ramsey show where we talk
about your relationships your mental
health your work your career
your money
it's all right here george regarding our
last call with that young 20 year old
young man there um earl nightingale who
uh was kind of the grandfather of the
motivational speaking movement back in
the 60s
he used to say in one of his
motivational talks that i listened to
when i was probably that young man's age
that too many people spend more time
picking out
a suit of clothes
than they do their career
and uh what we're trying to get to there
was you know how many people picked out
a career because their friend got a job
over there
dumb idea
you know people picked out a career
because their mama said you can make
good money doing that
dumb idea
you know and so ken coleman and we at
ramsey we spend our lives around here
trying to get you to
find something that aligns with your
talents and your passions
and that is that you're going to get joy
from
and you're going to make money and you
don't go spend a bunch of money on
education then
to become educated to do something that
you don't end up doing
and which is like everybody just about
right so um you know you really need to
parents uh don't do that to your kid
don't say
um oh you make good money hitting there
you gotta go over there uh why
no how about more like um
you have the this unbelievable ability
to see things mechanically
and it can lead you to a whole lot of
places yeah it's very important oh yeah
and parents it starts with the parents
and a lot of parents are pressuring
their kids for really terrible reasons
and go to this school because i went
there it's my alma mater and you got to
get this major because then you'll have
a steady job that you'll hate
and then you're going to end up trying
to switch careers and call us going i
hate my job my parents forced me into it
and so i just see that future of that
bright young man and i don't want to see
him calling us back on i hate hvac help
me get out of this i'm not sure hvac's a
a bad thing for him it's certainly not a
bad thing yeah but um the thing the
reason he was describing leaving that
one job is exactly what he's going to
get in the other one so it sounded like
frying pan into the fire to me
so um but it's it's
man you can do so much in the trades to
make money if you want to go in the
trades using your hands today we love
the trade it's um let's make that i
highly recommend them yeah but but get
into something where
you know you have a specific thing that
kind of gives you a little electricity
when you talk about it
other than just i can make some money
beth is in detroit hi beth welcome to
the ramsay show
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
call i'm a little bit star struck so
i'll try to get through this call george
does that that's what it is i was going
to say
that he does that yeah people get that
way when they're with him
well i am a long time listener for
simone caller and i appreciate you
taking my call i my husband and i are
just kind of getting our ducks in a row
a little bit late but still doing it
um and i'm interested in learning about
a ladybird deed and if you know anything
about it or can help me to know if
that's the right way for us to go okay
it's simply a life estate and the people
nicknamed it lady bird because lyndon
johnson did it with his wife
and so they nicknamed ladybird johnson
so they nicknamed it ladybird d but all
it means is is the that
for instance uh if you all had kids from
a pre if your husband had kids from a
previous marriage he wanted to leave the
house to the kids
he could leave you a life of state
meaning you're allowed to live there and
and the kids can't do anything with the
property as long as you're alive
okay it essentially clouds the title
i mean that you you are in control of
they can't refinance it
there's not really anything they can do
with it
without your permission if you if you
are given the life estate that would be
an example of how it's utilized how are
you talking about using it
well i mostly was i just wanted to make
it easy for them when we're not here
anymore to just take old you know do
whatever they want with it sell it oh
i wouldn't do that okay i'll just leave
it to you and i just what i do is do
mirror image wheels and a miriam binge
will says that if uh you die it all goes
to him if he dies it all goes to you and
if you both die you both are in
agreement on where it's all going
i think what about a medicare protection
you know how they go back so many years
if you medicaid
not medicare
oh medicaid oh forgive me okay
if you want to go into a welfare nursing
home
you want to get the property out of your
name five years before but i don't
recommend welfare nursing homes
that's what medicaid is welfare
medicaid's welfare
okay
definitely no i wouldn't plan to be
there okay so you need you need
long-term care insurance and money
long-term care insurance and money
are you 60
are you 60
62 and my husband's almost 64. perfect
do you you don't have long-term care
insurance to cover nursing home or
in-home care
well i'm embarrassed to say that i don't
that's okay okay no problem what's your
what's charles net worth how much money
have you got
probably uh between the house and
oh gosh i was a stay-at-home mom for a
long time so i did not we are not
totally
doing wonderfully but we have our home
that's paid for that might be worth
about 300. we've got probably about
150 in the bank and then we've got a
couple hundred in um
uh iras perfect you need long-term care
insurance go to ramseysolutions.com and
click on elp for long-term care and get
with one of our elps and they'll help
you get it going because here's the
scenario that usually happens where you
are if you had three million dollars if
you told me that in your retirement i
would have told you to self-insure
because you could pay for the nursing
home because average nursing home stays
not but 2.3 years
so you can pay for the nursing home or
in-home care but what but 75 of the
ladies out live their husbands
and so what normally happens is he
passes away or he goes into a nursing
home uses up your 300 grand on the
nursing home and then passes away and
leaves you broke with a paid for house
we don't want that
so we're going to get insurance to cover
the nursing home that's long-term care
insurance that's all you need and then
you need a will that leaves the house to
the kids for both of you that's all you
need dave what's the magic number about
60 we tell people get long-term care
insurance at 60. it's it's a statistical
thing uh a probability thing and the
probability of utilizing nursing home
services prior to age 60 is less than
one half of one percent
and it's weird almost every day after
you're 60 it goes up dramatically i mean
it's like a hockey stick curve right and
so um
you know you you need that now those of
you that are baby step millionaires and
have got five million dollars you're
probably not going to go to a nursing
home
you're probably going to hire 24-hour
in-home care which is not a whole lot
more
than a nursing home bill actually uh and
you can get you know be in your
environment and that's what i'll do in
other words in my situation if something
happens you'll miss out on bingo tonight
no question yeah and we're gonna take
care of this and um be in my own
environment being in control of the
whole situation more uh and one of us
will be whichever one is functioning and
but you know you can do that for uh for
more than a nursing home bill but if
you've got five million dollars you know
you're still not gonna burn through even
three or four hundred five hundred
thousand bucks of it you take care of
that person and you're still gonna be
okay so you self-insure in other words
through the
final days of care routine if you've got
substantial wealth but where she's got
the 300k that's the exact number they're
gonna burn through probably so they
definitely need to get long-term care
insurance she's right on that bubble
and uh and no you're not going to be
you're not even going to be eligible for
medicaid
no matter what you do
because the only way you get eligible
for medicaid is you have to prove that
you're broke which means you moved all
of your assets out of your name in order
to get welfare
and that's technically welfare fraud is
what that is so um
some people call it elder care law but
it's uh it's it's immoral is what it is
so no we don't recommend that that you
act like you're broke so the government
pays for stuff for you i don't recommend
that at all
but what a good question that's very
cool so but the life estate that's or
the lady bird deed that's such a cool
name you know i never heard ladybird
deed until the last few years it's kind
of they people started naming it that
more lately i grew up around the real
estate business we always just call life
of state life state that's really all it
is you got to give it a snappy name that
way people will do it yeah but you have
you know as long as you're alive you
have access to the property if you leave
life estate does that create any weird
relational pieces with the kids and
whoever's living there of course because
they want you to die at that point yeah
you're you're kind of yeah you're going
would you please
especially you know it's like stepmom
right because there's kids from a
previous marriage so we're like would
she die and get out of the way i want
the house
so but you can actually you could
actually sell
but you know you go okay i'll agree
everybody to sell it but i get some
money
you could do that if you hold the life
estate you don't
technically uh have to but i mean if you
want me to get out of the way you got to
pay me i like that prior to death all
right so there you go gives you
protection and gives you a place to live
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your
relationships
your mental health your money your job
your career we talk about your life all
right in front of you you we talk about
you right in front of you open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in the call is free and
some say the advice is worth exactly
what you pay for it rachel's with us in
kansas city hey rachel welcome to the
ramsay show
hi dave thanks for having me on i'm such
a big fan well i'm honored how can we
help
um i wanted to get your opinion on my
husband and i's living situation
we're currently on baby step 3b and we
found out a month ago that my husband
has cancer
so that's why
yeah that's why making the decision on
where to live is kind of a little bit
more complicated yeah
but we kind of have a couple options we
could either resign our lease which is
increasing to be about a fourth of our
take-home pay and just break it if we
find a house
the other option is both of our parents
offered for us to move in with them to
help save money until we find a house
but i honestly just wasn't sure if we
should continue our house search um
giving the diagnosis and
potential medical bills
and things like that
well that's a real scary word you're
throwing around what is the diagnosis
what's the situation
uh he has stage two non-child
non-hodgkin's lymphoma
okay
me not being a medical person tell me
what you think that means for your home
for the next two years
um what's he gonna what's he gonna go
through
well
right now he's declining radiation
treatment and but it might change in a
year or so the doctor said you could
just wait and see um
like it could just go away on its own or
we could just wait and watch it as an
option so
we were kind of thinking that unless it
gets worse for right now
so this is not life-threatening
um
no it doesn't sound like it but um
well certainly if you're declining
treatment it's either
devastatingly life-threatening and you
just don't want to go through the
treatment or it's not life-threatening
at all and you're not worried about
dying otherwise you take the treatment
right i don't know how this works but
help me with it right yeah my the doctor
said that since um he's so young that he
has seen it just go away before and he
said that anything past stage one you
wouldn't recommend treatment for it
so um he kind of changed his opinion now
and we're kind of getting second
opinions on where we're going from there
but
okay yeah i want to settle this before i
make a decision on housing
okay
because when i hear cancer i hear you've
got a fight on your hands and it doesn't
sound like that i was right
it sounds like you may not have a fight
on your hands so i mean if you're
getting ready to go into like two years
of chemo and we're going to be
concentrating on beating cancer it's
going to take
money spiritual resources financial
resources emotional resources it's going
to require everything you got in which
case you don't need to be buying a house
right but if that's not what's going on
it this sounds like you know you're
acting like he's got the flu here i
can't i don't mean to be certain i don't
mean to be sarcastic but i don't i'm i'm
not grasping so
if um
if if it's not if if it's not going to
affect your life or his life
then maybe we just go ahead and buy
okay but i would not go buy a house if
you're fighting
serious cancer battle
yeah yeah for sure
because you're gonna need the money and
the emotional bandwidth to fight it
yeah definitely
so i think that you see what i'm saying
yeah you know so i i
i and i'm not much help because i don't
understand um the the
the situation well enough medically to
uh to be a to be a much helper i mean
george do you know when is the lease up
uh the lease is up in may but we have to
resign by the end of february
okay would they be maybe willing to give
you an extension because of the health
circumstances
um
i could ask but
i mean they haven't been super helpful
so far so i don't know if that's
something that would be on the table
yeah yeah
well i just i mean i don't know your
relationship with your family and if
that's going to be you know emotionally
taxing to live with them or if it'd be a
great situation but it's not an urgent
thing where i go you got to move with
the family you got to save every dollar
you can you guys seem to be doing fine
right now so i think resigning the lease
is a fine idea if like dave saying we
don't know what this is going to look
like we don't know how much money this
is going to cost and renting versus home
ownership it's going to take a weight
off of you versus dealing with being a
homeowner
moving buying a home closing a home
dealing with all the issues of moving
dealing with the issues of maintenance
and everything else i would not put you
into a home right now
until you get until you get this solved
yeah and you know that it's in your rear
view mirror so either resign the lease
or move in with your parents
one of the two if you think it's going
to be in your rearview mirror in six
months maybe you move in with mom and
dad for a few months beginning in may
and between now and then go ahead and
start looking for a house
but you do need to get that second
opinion and get a firm
prognosis a firm treatment plan that
you're all in agreement on and then that
tells you how much of an impact this is
going to be to your life
yeah and then based on that you decide
if it's a major impact to your life
please do not buy a house while you're
fighting it but if it's a minor impact
the way you're describing it which is
kind of foreign to me you can tell i'm a
little confused by it i'm happy that
that's all it is i hope that's all it is
but if it's a minor impact then maybe
you are buying a home this summer
and uh you know when you may and
whatever sounds like a landlord i mean
you have to resign by the end of
february for may
i haven't heard something like that that
feels like if you you know if it's kind
of one of those things if you can get
away with get convincing people they
have to do that
sure
i don't know there's definitely not a
law that's the policy just do whatever
you want to do
very interesting
very interesting
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five it's tax season
and i don't know anyone who loves that
unless you're an accountant
uh even the people at the irs don't love
it the truth is most of us dread filing
taxes it's a pain and confusing and it's
bad and the tax software oh it hits you
with the extra fees they try to sell you
on more debt oh what a mess filing your
taxes does not have to be horrible we
created ramsey smart tax to give you
software you can actually trust
smart tax has steps that are simple
clear
you know you've done your taxes right no
more headaches no more second guessing
and we will not surprise you with add-on
fees
we will not sell your info to scummy
companies we will not give them the
opportunity to get you into debt you can
be assured of that and when you sign up
for ramsey plus it's even easier you can
actually file your federal taxes for
free
don't get taken advantage of by your tax
software ever again start a free trial
at ramsey plus and file your taxes for
free
go to ramseyplus.com
dot ramseysolutions.com and liquor
ramsay plus
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at
825-5225
sarah is with us
and sarah's in dallas texas hi sarah how
are you
[Music]
hi i'm great how are you doing better
than i deserve what's up
i want to thank you first of all my
husband i found you a few years ago and
didn't realize how much debt we were in
um with student loans and everything and
in the past four years we've paid off a
hundred and 160 thousand dollars of debt
and except for a house we're completely
debt free so way to go good for you you
do why'd it go yeah it's really exciting
and with home values we have a ton of
equity in our home now so it's great
good good
so
we're at the point now so we own a small
business we have a handyman at home you
know repair home services business
for the first few years it was my
husband and then we hired a guy
no now we've got two teams with two
vehicles vehicles are both completely
100 percent paid off
um
but we got so busy over the last couple
years we realized we really need to hire
admin people so in the last few months
we hired you know one office manager
he's doing all the invoices all the
stuff we used to do around the clock
answering phones estimates invoices and
one person that's handling you know
marketing and promotions and our website
and all that good stuff wow good for you
yeah so it's exciting and it's growth
but it's also the first time we've
really had overhead where like you know
even if our guys are in the field
working like we're still paying them
salary to be in the office
um so it's cutting it a little closer
than normal and
we have plenty of business we have a
great reputation
we have the work but we need to in order
to get to the next level in our business
we need to have a third team hire two
more guys get another vehicle
and then again that would add about our
projections would add about another 80
to 100 000 revenue you know to add
another team on
but our problem lies in the vehicle
right now in the short term cars are
appreciating in this weird market where
like
supply and demand is all wonky and cars
are supposedly going up in value to
where we've been searching for months
for like a chevy express like a small
box truck or a ford transit and we just
bought one in cash two years ago for 25
000. now they're selling for 45 or 50
000
and we don't have that much cash you
know just to buy it outright oh wow
the car market has gone bizarre
but it has not doubled
for the same exact car it did not 25 to
40 or 50.
you were trying to you're trying to get
a better car than the last one you
bought
well no they're exact same so we bought
a ford transit like a 2018 and we bought
it right at the beginning of 2020. it
had 15 000 miles on it we've put 30 000
miles on it since then and those same
exact car if we sold it tomorrow like on
facebook marketplace or on cargurus
they're selling for 43 to 45 000
like with the extra miles in used
condition they're selling for more so
we're either going to get that car or we
could go up to like a chevy express a
little bit bigger box truck but that was
only fine for 48 to 50.
so we could we could definitely get a
smaller car because we're looking for
you
in our emergency fund so not all of it
this is not an emergency this is not an
emergency
exactly you can't use your emergency
fund to grow your business it's not an
emergency
very true
so you don't have the money if you don't
have the money
okay
so you don't buy the truck you don't you
don't have the crew so continue to save
just because
you need to make some money to grow your
business your business should grow with
money it makes
yeah
so you guys don't do any retained
earnings or anything like that no
savings
uh
savings like our personal account you
mean do you have any money saved that is
not retirement accounts
oh just the 22 000 our emergency fund
and then the in our home so you don't
have the money to do this deal
you shouldn't even be talking about this
that's your personal emergency fund or
is this just for the business
i mean it's our personal emergency fund
yeah they don't have it but they don't
have a business emergency fund they
don't have any money you know when it's
a small
small business like one and the same
yeah
so here's what's here's what's happening
okay
uh you're about to
step into the classic trap that small
business people do all the time
you're about to you've gotten so excited
about this and you built it up in your
head that you're about to step over into
stupid to expand your business
okay and you're about to go into debt to
buy a dad gum truck
to add crews and you're not even gonna
break even on it for two and a half
years
no
well and the only reason we're not tr
we're not trying to justify it but we
would never do that with a personal
vehicle it just sits it's a system
driver this is going to make us money
this would if we add another crew that's
8 200 000 revenue so we're thinking well
that is justified because we have that
is justifying yeah that's the very
definition of justified
okay you're rationalizing your butt off
the budget where you're rationalizing
your product like a year you're gonna do
this no matter what i tell you
please don't do it
please i beg you
i've grown a 300 million dollar business
with cash that the business made
one year at a time for 30 years
i have not ever borrowed money i'm
sitting in a studio that cost two
million dollars just for the freaking
studio and i i needed the studio to
broadcast but we didn't do this until we
could pay cash for it
and that way when the freaking pandemic
hits and all revenue stops i don't go
out of business because i don't have
debt hanging around my net for an
overpriced truck please don't do this
okay please
now here's what you do need to do
i think your prices are too low
okay you haven't raised your prices at
all in the last three years have you
actually we have how much we have twice
how much um
it
used to be you know like 60 an hour per
guy and then it was 80 and now it's
almost 95 an hour
you're doing better than i guessed i was
wrong i was wrong you're doing better
than i guessed because um
so your margin should be going up on all
this paid for stuff then and it
shouldn't be that close yeah so what's
your top line what's your gross revenues
uh it's about 240 000
okay and what's your net on that that
you paid taxes on
uh 140.
that's great margin
it's a great margin okay out of 140 i
want you to start saving money to buy a
used van to add the third crew
and when you have the money add the
third crew
but not until you've got them
the money
listen here's the thing the businesses
that stay open
don't run out there on the edge of thin
ice borrowing money in order to expand
expand expand as if there's no tomorrow
because there is a tomorrow and it might
have a pandemic in it
and then you get yourself in a crack and
just don't do this don't do it and you
guys you paid off 160k in four years and
that tells me you're not scared of doing
the hard work and so how quickly could
you save up 40 grand if you did that
that's 40 grand a year they did it so
you know
40 50 grand you can save in a year
based on that ratio and you can go pay
cash for this fan
um
i gotta tell you i mean i she sounds
like she's done the research on the van
i'm having a real hard time believing
that but i may have happened i may just
be that much out of touch i am aware
cars have gone up considerably on the
short term here but i was not aware and
you know maybe the construction business
is completely booming out of control too
and that's running those types of
vehicles doubling the pressure on the
vans more than just normal and i'm going
to drive this car can you get a cheap
pickup truck for now that'll do the job
just for right now i don't know what you
need really need to do this i don't have
any idea but i i
pay cash for whatever you're going to do
and you know you you do not justify this
you just worked to get out of that and
then you called me trying to get back in
that what did you expect me to do
and what happens is they go well if we
got two trucks dave then we could have
200k more because we and then
you got eight trucks but then you got
eight hundred thousand dollars in debt
you know starting to get started about
the potential revenues without looking
at the risk
there's this thing you don't know what
you don't know until you're there
and then you're gonna learn and please
you're just adding so much risk and
they've worked so hard to get out of
this debt on their personal side go back
in what's all personal debt believe me
they're not loaning that little business
any money at the bank they're loaning
that woman money
she'd be signing personally
don't do this please don't do it please
please don't move you got dave crying
now it's a bad situation
don't cry no it's okay just whining
there's a difference
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage abby is
with us hey abby how are you hi i'm good
how are you better than i deserve
welcome welcome good to have you so
where do you live uh in champaign
illinois good for you and all the way
here to do your debt-free scream yes sir
how much you paid off 68
963 dollars and 34 cents i love it good
for you and your range or how long did
this take you 35 months okay and your
range of income during that three years
i started out at about 14 and ended at
about 65. whoa
nice jump well done what kind of debt
was the 69 000 all student loans okay
when did you get out of school 2018
three years ago yep okay so you got out
of school and game on yep
well i got i got to tell you i uh
actually want a copy of your t-shirt to
take home and i'm going to make my i'm
going to make my wife wear it
let's see it says
because dave says so oh my goodness the
chance that sharon's wearing that's zero
i'll just tell you but i love it very
cool it's amazing i bet you get some
questions about that i just got it so i
haven't yet but we'll get there
we'll work on stirring up a ruckus okay
good for you
so the debt was 69 000 student loans you
get out of school and game on yeah so i
had i was in a five year program so i
could sit for the cpas and about senior
years when i started to freak out a
little bit they sent me a nice little
email that said oh by the way your
payment's going to be about 650 a month
and at the time i just had this little
part-time job so
not good yeah so i talked to my sister
and she told me about this dave ramsey
guy and of course i said i would go look
into it and i totally forgot about it
but one night i was laying in bed and i
could not get to sleep and i thought a
nice finance podcast would be the
perfect thing to you know bore me off
so i pulled it up thinking it's going to
be some like scholarly
dry thing that's what dave's known for
yeah i'm kind of known for being
scholarly
dry dry that's me so it came on this is
like two o'clock in the morning the
music starts blaring and i'm like it's
the wrong podcast it was not in fact the
wrong podcast so i kind of listened over
the next few days and i liked it but it
wasn't i mean it didn't change my life
at that point then i found out about the
book and i'm a huge book nerd so we got
the book and that is when we became the
card carrying member of the dave ramsey
cult oh my gosh wow
i'm so honored wow i didn't know we had
cards it took a book this is good yeah i
need one of those we need cards cards
and shirts cards t-shirts
goes with the thing why'd it go kiddo
i'm proud of you wow so they don't teach
this in finance and accounting this idea
of getting out of debt i wasn't taught
when i got my finance degree you weren't
taught when you got your accounting
degree i did not but you sat for him
past your cpa i did it took a while but
we got through it
good for you
obviously a sharp cookie well done good
for you so big job landed and all that
and that's how you go from 14 to 65. um
so actually i had trouble getting a job
at first and i finally managed to get
one but um so coveted in 2020
and the little part-time job dropped off
and i picked up a consulting job
and then while i was doing the
consulting job i realized i wasn't
really happy at my position that i had
so i went to a new position but they
couldn't find a replacement for me so i
stayed on the old position so i had
three jobs and that's what got me up to
the 65. oh okay cool what are you doing
today
um now i am a staff accountant for a
local healthcare clinic and i just have
one of the part-time jobs now good for
you good for you well done
well done proud of you good work so the
podcast led to the book
and
led you to go i'm going to do this yes
and um the good news is is that
accountants know systems and when you
see a system you just plug into the
system it really is just math once you
get into it
and behavior which clearly you did some
different things yes what was the
hardest part of this process for you man
so being an accountant like seeing all
the money that i was wasting on not
putting it into retirement just made me
cry a little inside
and then the worst part for me was i'm
kind of an emotional shopper so like if
you're having a bad day you go on find
something cool and when you're working
like three jobs you're studying for the
cpa which is almost another part-time
job it's a lot of rough days so i would
like go online you know find something
put it in the cart like rachel says add
to cart
and i would get as far as the checkout
and see the total and just tear would
roll down my cheeks because i closed the
browser window
and did not did not hit submit wow and
they sent you an email that said you
left items in your cart we miss you come
back there's a coupon come on wow we
thought we had you hooked
you got off the hook
but it was all worth it yes stuff
definitely wow all right so who were
your biggest cheerleaders uh my parents
were pretty happy that i was doing it
especially since one of them was a
parent plus loan so they were happy to
see that go out the window
my co-worker courtney she's actually on
baby step two as well so she was always
down for a good day of conversation
and really the rest of it was the baby
steps facebook community is insanely
amazing every time i paid off a loan i
would go on there you know five left
four left three left and every single
time i would get hundreds of comments
from people that didn't even know me and
they would say you're doing so great
come on you're gonna make it we're so
proud of you
and for me because i'm single that was
everything it really helped push me
through when i was having rough times
yeah the baby steps community is
powerful it really is and they do a
great job of encouraging and
accountability if you step outside the
line they will tell you in there i'm
just telling you they're pretty hardcore
they're not scared to share their their
card carrying yes that's what they are
yeah
that's pretty good too
do what no their meme gabe is pretty
good too dave ramsey memes okay yeah
we'll send them to you dave okay we'll
fill you in
i heard this it happened
dave stays off of facebook yeah
i do now but yeah you can be sure i'm
off of it but i do love that group it
really is incredible to see all the
encouragement support and having people
around you especially for for single
people out there it can be feel lonely
doing this plan and i love that you got
connected and you made those moves to
have those people around you we're so
proud of you yeah we're proud of you
you're amazing what a sharp sharp young
woman very very well done well we got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
how ordinary people build extraordinary
wealth and how you can too that's your
next chapter in your story the number
two
job in the millionaire survey of people
that become millionaires
accountants so she's destined this is
where she's
i'm not paying other people interest
this is the deal and a copy total money
makeover the book that helped you we'll
give you another copy you can give it
away and stir up some
kind of a ruckus the way you're going to
do with that t-shirt or yours so good
for you so proud of you well done very
very well done all right it's abby
champaign illinois 69 000 paid off in 35
months making 14 to 65. count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three two
one i'm debt-free
[Applause]
[Music]
that is how it's done
i love it
absolutely fabulous
renee is in knoxville hey renee welcome
to the ramsay show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um i sold a house last year
and
i still had to pay back some of the
mortgage
so i got probably about a third of it
back from equity and i wanted to know
what the best way to invest for like a
short term right now i have it in a 15
month cd because i i play it safe
okay
well what are you going to use it for
um
i'm not sure maybe another home in the
future
i'm
going on 54 and
it's not a lot of money but i don't want
to how much money is somewhere safe
um
i really don't want to say
i mean it's not a lot but nobody knows
where you are darling it's okay you're
in freaking knoxville i mean it's not
like 10 or 100 grand
that's 100. good for you okay that's
they're not going to come look you up
for 100. don't worry yeah you said 10
million somebody might come find you but
all right so uh a hundred thousand
dollars and you you are you gonna buy a
house in the next three years you think
um possibly yeah i believe in the cd
then three to five years i'm just
leaving that cd it's not making anything
but you're not gonna lose anything and i
don't want you i don't want you not
sleeping for the next three years and i
got a feeling if i put you in a mutual
fund you're gonna not sleep
because you're gonna worry about
everything the news says for the next
three years yeah under three years
there's just a lot of risk going on and
so once that cd the 15 month's over i
might move it into something more liquid
like a high yield savings account you
might get a half a percent woohoo but
that's not the point we want to protect
this money instead of letting it you
know fall up and down on the market
while you lose sleep over it yeah you're
not making anything you're just parking
it safely
matter of fact you're going backwards
because inflation's eating you up but
you're doing it for a short period of
time no big deal you're just it's just a
parking lot that's all it is just not
having to pay for parking that's it free
parking i like that that's a good way to
put it is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
talking about your life we're glad
you're here david's with us in atlanta
hi david how are you
hey bob thank you guys so much for
taking my call sure what's up
hey so um
i'm 34 years old um i'm married i have
five kids
and we're kind of in a little bit of a
tough spot right now okay so
uh last year we purchased a house
there's
312 000. we are 300 000 on it right now
um and so
the
the issue is that we have a house right
now
that
is uh
we
we have a rental property
that is completely um it's completely
paid off
the rental itself for 225.
yes sir okay
okay um
the issue is that right now
we're
we're in about 46 000 in credit card
debt
and
we're just
you know my wife and i were new to the
baby steps um and we're to the point
where you know like at work
the ceiling burned out you know all the
money that would that that would come in
would immediately leave
you know and it just kind of feels like
we're leaving like you know we're living
paycheck to paycheck because you are
that's why it feels that way yeah
yeah what's your income household
so
right now
last year was 85 000
um
the year before that we're around 95 92
000
okay so about nine do you think you'll
do this year
um
uh you know i would say a safe number
maybe like 75 to 80 000. okay are you
guys doing a budget i know you said
you're new to the steps are you doing a
monthly budget on paper
and tracking it
yeah so we actually just started working
on one um
so yes yes we are okay you're just
getting started with the budget it
sounds like
yes because we got to find out where all
this money's going i mean you guys make
a decent income and it sounds like
there's nothing at the end of the month
and so we've got to figure out where
these money leaks are in the budget if
this is going to eating out if this is
going towards online shopping but we
gotta batten down the hatchets here and
get rid of this forty six thousand
dollars in debt we'll worry about the
mortgage later on in the baby steps
right so
you know i think a lot of it was eating
out you know we were eating algiers the
money was just evaporating um and so
what my wife was doing
was pretty much we were living off of
credit cards yeah and so
you know now
you know we find ourselves ourselves in
this situation we're scrambling around
you know we're trying to pay down um you
know the debts from smallest uh you know
largest we're doing the instacart uber
and it's just
well let me tell you let me tell you
what let me tell you what i think is
happening and i it seems pretty
looking at it from this side anyway
you're 34 years old you got five kids
you work both work
y'all are running wide open all the time
your lives are unbelievably busy
it's very hectic and in the middle of
hectic you do two things one is you
become disorganized which never is an
efficient use of money and two is you
buy a lot of things that are time saving
things eating out as a time saver
yep anything you can do because you're
tired
you're exhausted you're frenetic you're
going crazy
the kids are screaming because you got
little kids you haven't got five
teenagers
you're out your house is wild
yep and you know in the middle of all of
that
um you're just trying to survive
and and so you're not doing anything
where you're telling things what to do
you're reactive instead of proactive on
everything
yeah pretty much yeah so what's going to
happen is when you go through financial
peace university
and you learn to become proactive and
doing the budget is a step of being
proactive
when you put every dollar on paper you
and your wife put those kids to bed turn
off the stupid television
book a night where you say we're going
to spend two hours on this first budget
because the first budget's really hard
and you're going to put it in the every
dollar app so both of you can track it
and i'm going to give you a year
different to ramsey plus so you can go
through financial peace university and
run the every dollar premium version of
the budgeting app okay
now when you start making when you start
making this money behave
you're getting ahead of it instead of
behind it
then when you're tired and you get ready
to buy something you have to look at the
budget and see if you have the money
right you're going to get a raise it's
going to feel like you got a raise when
you get on a budget
now so here's my question you know being
so um i'm 30 you know 34 years old
um we have nothing insane i know
absolutely nothing interesting the only
equity we have is well so the house that
we just purchased that it's already
gained some equity about forty thousand
dollars yeah and then the house that's
paid off we have a you know another
225 on a conservative side
so
my question is would you guys sell that
property i'm not trying to fix the
symptom i'm trying to fix the problem
okay
this the the credit card debt is a
symptom
of you being out of control and
disorganized
well let me tell i'm absolutely done
with that all right i'm going to cut off
all my credit cards like there's no way
in the world i'm going back to that so
what i would tell you to do is let's get
on this budget and you two get in this
class and the two of you
get a calm
money rhythm as a couple
where you're behaving for about 60 to 90
days before you make a real estate
decision
okay let's start beating on these credit
cards using the debt snowball to begin
to pay them down you're not going to
make a huge progress but about 90 days
from now i'm going to sell the rental
but i don't want you do it right now
because right now you're scrambling
trying to find a way to fix this and i
don't want you to fix this because the
this is
you right we gotta fix you we gotta get
you guys in a rhythm and get you guys in
a behavior
the rental property then can use be used
to clean up the credit cards when we
know they're not gonna grow back because
now we're on a new system we have a new
way of doing things a new life when it
comes to money a new set of principles
that we operate by
more than it's just i'm done with this
and done with us it's a good place to
start
but that's not a principle that will
drive you for 10 years
okay so then you sell the rental then
you pay off the credit cards and then we
pay off your mortgage
yeah so okay so you're saying go through
financial peace university then decide
if we're gonna go ahead and sell the
rental property yes i think you are
gonna sell it but i wouldn't until
you've done this because you're going to
be selling it for a different
emotional reason than you are today
you've been flailing around so long that
right now selling the rental property is
flailing
but when it's purposeful and intentional
and as a part of an overall strategy 90
days from now it's a whole different way
to sell it in a whole different place in
your psyche that you're sitting when
you're making that decision you're a
smart guy david
you just got you just got a lot of irons
in the fire yeah i mean you're juggling
flaming swords dude and what we're
saying is we want to see behavior change
so that you have long lasting financial
success and right now selling is just a
shortcut and you could be back in the
same rhythms yeah you were beforehand
and so most people doing this plan david
they'll be out of debt in 18 to 24
months and you guys absolutely can do
that just based on the numbers without
even selling this rental property and so
that's what i want to see is some
gazelle intensity and obviously you got
five kids man your life is crazy but we
gotta find some margin shave some
expenses bring in some more income and
get creative and get this thing out of
your life and never look back yeah and
then the burnout will start to go away
because you're you're burnt out because
you're you're a rat in the wheel
you don't feel traction once you start
seeing some traction from your work the
work takes on more meaning
and but you have to say have a sense of
we're going somewhere with this not like
we're just spinning out yeah and uh
that's where you're headed dude you're
gonna do fine six months from now if
you'll do the stuff we're teaching you
your life is going to be completely
different your attitude your heart rate
when you're talking about this is going
to change the tightness across the top
of your shoulders is going to release
all of this is going to happen that's
why we call it financial peace two words
that don't go together like fouchy math
and so you know check it out
ramseysolutions.com
and you can plug into financial peace
university we're gonna plug you in
though you hold on and we're gonna sign
you up for a year's worth and get you
going
good stuff like my new joke george i
like that it's good joke you've improved
i'm moving along it's a little nicer
than it used to be back during cove but
i was more nasty during the now it's
soft it's just now it's just calm now
it's just funny
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsey
show you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host thank you for joining
us america it's a free call george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your
mental health your relationships your
job your career your money we talk about
everything here on the ramsay show we're
glad you're with us triple eight eight
two five five two two five is the number
jalen starts off this hour in atlanta
georgia hi jalen what's up
hi sir thank you so much for taking my
call sure how can we help
yes sir so i just actually learned about
the baby steps and all that you've done
starting in january but
in december i made the stupid maybe
smart decision uh i ordered a tesla
model y and learning that it's 60 000
and that will put me in debt i turned
around as like okay that may not be the
best idea but then i came up with the
idea of doing research that i could
generate into passive income by renting
on suro and allowing others to you know
drive do have a rental property
essentially for the vehicle and make
that income back and paying off the debt
with that however i'd still be risking
having that debt because if things
happen and i'm not able to rent the car
out and things like that i could still
be withheld i'm paying almost at 900
monthly car note so i just wanted to
know if that's a good idea i'm 23 i'm
single i don't have any other debt
except for my current car which is my
kso but it's currently in positive
equity and i'm just continuing paying
that off learning from the baby steps so
just really want some advice with this
all right there's a lot going on here
jalen but i'm glad you found us is it
interesting dave they always find you
right after they do a dumb thing and
then a month later they go and i found
dave
it's amazing but let me let me answer
your question so you've got dead on the
key of soul and you're going i got a
business making opportunity by getting a
sweet toy and letting someone else
destroy it while i slowly painfully pay
back the debt on two cars now that's a
different way than he said it george
you're right that's the way i heard it
i'll say that jalen so no
do not get this tesla you need to pay
off this kia soul and if you do ever get
a tesla i want you to do it with cash
how much money do you make
so i just got a promotion actually in
january as well so i'm currently going
to be at 50 000 plus incentives you said
60 000
yes so you're going to own a 60 000 car
making 60 000 a year
when you put it that way it sounds even
worse okay
that's why he did that that's why he did
it
he's completely messing with you he's
doing he's doing it because he loves you
i love you and i want you to win
financially and the turo tesla deal is
not going to be the business model you
you think yes so jalen um here's the
thing you really good question and i
really appreciate you calling sir
um a good way to make some of these
decisions
is to
pan way back
and say okay when i'm 35
12 years from now
which will be the best decision
and it kind of instantly leads you to
not doing the tesla thing and getting
the car paid off and starting to build
some wealth doesn't it
right but
the tesla only sounds good when you
think about taking delivery on it it
doesn't sound right when you're 35 you
have a 35 you have a 12 year old battery
at that point with some wheels
right right and with my current car now
since i can get more than what it's
worth paying off the
the loan should i
what is the balance of the car that i
have what's the balance so iowa fourteen
thousand members offering the seventeen
no just pay it off just just work
yourself you got a job just work your
work your way out of it and then if you
wanna trade cars do it with cash later
but let's just you have a small car debt
making fifty thousand
sixty thousand and let's turn around and
get it paid off as quick as we can um
because again so the other thing i
always ask myself is what
and and i went broke when i was 28
lost everything because i was stupid so
one of the things i started doing at
that point i started talking to old rich
people
i didn't want to talk to young rich
people i had been him he was stupid i
want to talk to old people who had money
made it and kept it
okay
and and then i've continued that for the
last 30 years that discussion with old
rich people to the point we did a
detailed in-depth research of the
largest research
study ever done on millionaires in north
america
and the number of millionaires out of
the 10 000 millionaires that we studied
the number of of them that said they
became a millionaire because they went
in debt to buy their car so they could
rent it out was precisely zero
none of them used your plan that you
presented to us a while ago
and so
you know and and because it's it's it's
just fraught with disaster there's so
many things that can go wrong in that
plan
that you laid out there and um
you know if you've ever had a rental
property or ever put a property out as
an airbnb
you would know not to put your car out
in that system because people just don't
take care of it
people are gross as a matter of fact
they're just gross they're filthy
animals
and so you really find that out about
them when they live in stuff or will
drive stuff that you own
and it's just you're gonna discover that
with your 60 000 car with your sixty
thousand dollar income so please don't
do it i think you're not going to i
think we talked you out of it but just
for the other people listening that are
thinking in the same way i want to make
sure we
drive the stake deeply into the ground
on that so
yeah pan
back ask yourself what would old rich
people do
because that's what you want to be
rich
when you're old
and dave when it comes to spending
decisions i like to think of it through
a framework where i go okay is this let
me have some self-awareness is this
gonna add value to my life is it born
out of my values and i move on to
motivation and this is where it gets
really tough especially for young people
what's my motive do i have a good motive
in buying this thing am i trying to flex
on my friends
do i want a shiny cool toy so i feel
successful and then i go into
affordability and i go can i afford this
in cash and if america answered that
correctly no one would be in debt would
they
and then you go into research mode and
go is this the best price retailer
option that i can get and then you go
into timing and you go all right is this
the right time to buy this what's the
opportunity cost could i wait a year
could i wait three years and when you do
that it actually spells smart which is
really cute
but what it does it helps you just take
a pause and think through a framework to
go
is this the right decision for where i'm
at financially and if you answer no to
any of those here's what it means not
now we're not saying we never want you
to have nice stuff i want you to drive a
model y tesla one day jalen but i want
you to do it when you get your income up
you can pay cash for this thing it's a
small portion of your life in your world
and you're not doing it to flex on other
people and you've done it because you're
already out of debt and you're investing
that that changes the game
you know i
very few
there's so many people we're a car
culture
uh and cars until the last 18 months go
down in value then they will again as
soon as this little supply demand curve
thing quits they will depreciate again
and so it's the largest thing we buy
that goes down in value and once you've
gotten past transportation to take your
family somewhere or to take yourself to
work once you've gotten past that the
car is no longer a need everything above
basic transportation is a want
and sadly in my life when i was young
before i was 30 years old
it was we didn't call it flexing but
it's just trying to impress other people
trying to keep up with the joneses
trying to make somebody think i bought a
jaguar them so that people would think i
was successful yeah based on the car you
drive that's your measure but that's
what people do and i was that shallow i
was that dumb
jalen's not that dumb no
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
well if you've been paying attention to
the real estate market you've noticed uh
it's crazy
competition's high to buy a property in
part because availability available
inventory has been hitting all-time lows
uh now when inventory is low it simply
means there are more buyers buying than
sellers selling which turns the pressure
up
to win in this market if you're buying
with it highly competitive among buyers
you don't need to be an amateur you need
to have a pro in your corner if you're
going to sell in this market to maximize
you need a pro in your corner
you need to do this do it the right way
get one of our endorsed local providers
the people the real estate agents
they're the high octane high protein
some of the best producers in your area
have been vetted by us
will connect you with that pro their
years of industry success will cause you
to have a positive transaction
in a weird and wacked out world go to
ramseysolutions.comagent
ramseysolutions.com
agent jared is with us in detroit hi
jared how are you
hey guys thanks for taking the call it
is a snowy day up here so whoa
absolutely um i i've been listening to
you guys for about the last year or so
on a regular basis i'm a 31 year old
bachelor who's also the primary provider
and caregiver for my two parents
um
right before covent hit i have a student
loan debt of 48 000
or so
and i'm getting ready to pay that off
here at the end of the month
so 23 months get that all cleared out
so my main question is
what would be the next best step
given that
you know i'm
living with mom and dad and helping take
care of them
um in this time that they need
um as well as trying to tell me tell me
about that
yeah so just um some chronic health
issues with both of them um financial
issues with them and i've been the one
to uh
step up and uh lend a hand to them as
the siblings are out of town
so are you living with them yeah you
said he was yeah okay so so you're
getting free
rent uh i i'm actually i'm providing the
funds for the house oh
so they're getting free rent how old are
they
late 60s
okay what's the nature of their chronic
health
um dad has lung and back issues mom has
just the aches and pains and
not able to you know take care of dad
herself
she's unemployed he has been a private
music teacher for many years so
income was never
steady so they have no money
they're both on social security yeah and
how much do you collect on social
security on them
between the two of them it's just under
3 000 a month
and then i went out um and a family from
my church
provided an open door for me and that's
how i've been able to pay off this stat
they brought me in they own the
landscaping company and they brought me
in to run the office and run the sales
department
last february and it's been a great
opportunity
and i'm looking to stay with them for
years on down the road okay are you 41
years old and still doing this
31 no i'm saying 10 years from today
um at least doing the job with them yes
no
your parents
if that's what is needed that's what i
would say yes
because i feel morally obligated to do
that
okay
but i would also uh since i'm going to
be paying off the debt
um would i would like to step back when
you're when you're 51. 20 years from now
you're still taking care of your parents
if i have to yes sir
okay
i really appreciate your
sense of honor
and i appreciate your heart
um
that's not sustainable i disagree
and it's not a moral obligation for you
to give your life away to take care of
these folks who did not bother to take
care of themselves just because they
happen to be your dna and i'm not trying
to be cold or mean but uh when i str
when i do this on a short term i'm with
you but when i stretch it out 20 years
i'm no longer with you on it
you and your siblings need to arrange
for their care a different way so that
you young men have a life
that's the hard thing is that the
siblings will not speak
yeah
why
because of the way my dad acted
i don't know yeah i know i've tried to
try and you know
bridge a gap because i do respect that
they have their own families
and then like hey i'm the one here with
mom and dad how can i help and they go
they've not really given me anything to
try and
pursue any options yeah
do you have dreams of having a family
getting married all that
if the lord wills
well i just don't want to see you held
back by all those opportunities because
you're taking care of mom and dad i want
i'm not suggesting we throw them in the
street and that we're cold and that
you're dishonorable you are a very
honorable young man i appreciate that
there's not many people that are
honorable anymore and i really
appreciate your sense of duty um it's a
wonderful thing but i do want you to
think beyond
uh on this and and start
what you've laid out here is not a
sustainable
quality of life for you
and it is not honorable at some point it
just becomes dysfunctional
so you've got to reach out there and say
okay
we're going to reach a point where we're
going to change this living arrangement
to x or y
and we're going to get the siblings
involved or mom and dad we're going to
find something they can live on
you know it may be medicaid nursing home
at some point because they would qualify
for that
it may be whatever i don't know and i'm
not trying to throw them out in the
street today
but this uh we're gonna do this in
perpetuation and call it honor i'm not
with you on that i'm gonna disagree
even though i admire your honor and i
admire your principle and i think it's
wonderful
for a period of years even that you take
care of them i have no issue with that
but this idea that you do this for 20
years is absurd dude it's absurd
so you need to rethink how we're going
to take care of them who's going to get
involved how we're going to
house them and feed them
so that you can begin to move past this
because this is a very very
um
it's not it's just it's not emotionally
spiritually financially sustainable yeah
and i'm hoping maybe we can get mom back
to a certain level of health where she
can take care of dad if she's in better
shape
you know get her health taken care of
versus you having to put your life on
hold to do this yeah you just gotta
start finding some kind of an off-ramp
strategy somewhere out there in your
mind rather than in perpetuation and
when you've got that then that will
affect the answer to your question see
that will affect how you work out the
baby steps how you build wealth how you
have a life
how you do these other things because
the girl that's going to marry into this
situation doesn't exist
she's not there
um you know it's a hard pill to swallow
but boy it's just she's not i mean it's
not and it's not because she's
dishonorable yeah
or mean or lacking in mercy or something
like that it's just she's going to
recognize this
as a mess and not jump in the middle of
it we're seeing this this trend the
sandwich generation what they call them
you know millennials gen x they're
having to take care of their parents
they're trying to take care of the kids
and it just puts stress on everyone it
can create resentment it can leave you
broke because you can't hit your own
financial goals you're trying to support
everyone on all ends yep it's a toxic
situation yeah and and you there's a
you know henry cloud's book boundaries
is what we're talking about here
and again it's not
lacking in love it's not lacking in
principle it's not liking an honor uh
it's not lacking in morality
uh you know honor the bible says to
honor your father and mother it does not
say to honor their misbehavior it honors
the position of father position of
mother if your mother does cocaine we're
not honoring that that's not what the
bible's talking about i was talking
about honoring the position of mom as a
position but not mom's misbehavior it's
about respect for mom's dysfunction or
dad's misbehavior dad's misdis
dysfunction that's not what we're
talking about and so
you know
but somewhere out of these two you ended
up with a tremendous sense of duty and
that
that's a wonderful thing for you to have
it's gonna carry you a long way in a
positive way if you learn to
put reasonable guardrails on it
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today jake's in indianapolis hi
jake how are you
hey george hey dave how are you guys
doing great man what's up
hey i got what uh should be a pretty
easy question
i am
getting ready to
go overseas with the military and um
i pretty consistently invest 15
into my roth tsp
and i was just wondering
once i get overseas and my salary is tax
free
does that make any sort of difference um
my wife also invests in her roth 401k so
i just want to get your take on that
no it doesn't change your thing
okay so just consider just keep the 15
in the roth tsp
you know in the tsp we're 80 c
10 percent s 10 i
okay great i appreciate your help what
branch of service are you in
uh the army
special forces
uh i'm a medic in uh
traditional army it's a conventional so
well thank you for your service yeah
it's a wild time to be doing what you're
doing
yeah yep they keep us on our toes i
guess yeah i guess
i guess they do
yeah thank you brother thank you
yeah take care of yourself
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five dakota is in
sioux falls south dakota hi dakota wait
a minute dakota in dakota
yes sir
you get that a lot
actually i just moved here
back in april okay so now you're going
to get that a lot okay yep so how can we
help
hello um so i am 19 years old um and i
am wanting to start a duck cleaning
business in about three months roughly
um
and the current job i'm working for is
kind of what i've been doing for the
company i worked for now
but
the problem is um i'm only making 13 an
hour doing it
and i actually just got a raise to
giving me a 65 cent raise
and i could go work at fast food making
15 or 16 an hour
so i'm trying to decide if i should
leave this company and go make a little
bit more for a while or if i stay with
this company
so you're wanting to start your own
business you said dunk hut duck hunting
no duct cleaning duct queen i was like
duck hunting business okay stop cleaning
okay and you're you're saying you can
make more go and work for fast food or
should i start this business but you
definitely wanted to leave the company
that you're with right now
well um i know i could make more at fast
food but i'm definitely starting this
business it's just kind of waiting for
the money to do it
hmm
do you want to be in the duck cleaning
business are you excited about it
yeah i'm excited to start my own company
doing it
um okay
i i never want to dissuade somebody from
going into business because i love small
business and i believe in small business
um and i never want to
be condescending to someone because of
their age but it is impossible for you
to have much business acumen at 19 years
old
of knowing what it takes to run a
business you may know how to do the duct
work cleaning you may not know how to do
the job but doing the job is only one
part of running the business there's
marketing there's dealing with customers
banking
setting up the llc getting the p ls
going doing the accounting
running the business is a multifaceted
thing
and unless you're a highly unusual 19
year old you probably don't have that
expertise those tools in your belt yet
i'm not saying you can't get them uh but
i really wouldn't want to learn uh
on the job
meaning i wouldn't want to try to learn
how to run a business while i'm running
a business it's a it's a very rough go
so
what i would try to do is um
work yourself into with the current
company
the duct cleaning business i would try
to work yourself into the operations
side of the business not just doing the
work and start to be mentored
apprenticed in a sense on how the
business actually operates
does that make any sense
yeah
and am i wrong or do you have some kind
of business background that i'm
that i that i should have known before i
opened my mouth
no i and the accounting stuff definitely
is what scares me the most out of it you
know yeah
so if you could work
in the office
part of the week
and um even for less money
and learn how the business operate the
operational parts of the business i
think you do know the technical part i
think you can successfully go clean the
ducts yeah am i right about that
yeah okay so you can actually perform
the job but that's a lot different than
running the business so here's what i've
run into a lot dakota over the years
whether it's 19 or 29 or 49
an
example in a different business would be
someone that is a chef
at a restaurant and they're very well
known they become they become actually
kind of famous locally for the quality
of their food the beauty of their dish
they they're become a gourmet chef and
suddenly they
decide that means they need to open a
restaurant
well creating the meal is the equivalent
of you cleaning the duct agreed
but running the restaurant involves
dealing with servers it involves dealing
with the valets out front it involves uh
dealing with the hostess that didn't
show up the software for the seating
and the reservations it involves again
the accounting the marketing for the
restaurant uh the the couponing system
that you're going to use or not usually
you have a whole business plan that the
chef doesn't know squad about and they
go broke
and i see this over and over and over
and over again uh that someone who is a
specialist in a certain area that can
perform the task
confuses that with running a business
they're two separate skill sets
performing the task is your entry point
but you've got to learn the other skill
sets hold on i'm going to send you a
copy of the book entree leadership which
was a number one best seller on how
we've grown and run this business and
that'll begin to help you put some of
these tools in your belt but i recommend
before you open the business that you
get a few more of these tools in the
belt and don't learn on the job yeah and
i i love seeing i think there's more and
more young people out there as i'm kind
of scanning social media who want to
work for themselves they want to run a
lot of business i think it's awesome but
there is a piece of that where you've
got to understand what you're getting
into and it's not just all starry-eyed
i'm going to make so much money and i
get to keep it all and be the boss well
i don't want to talk to you when you're
24 where you went bro
because you opened something and didn't
know how to run it that's what i don't
want that for you yeah i do want you to
be 24 and have opened two years ago at
22
after spending the previous three years
learning how to run the business and now
we're successful you got to see someone
successfully not it's not that
that you know i opened my first business
when i was 24. so
um you know i'm not against that at all
and i love the entrepreneurial spirit i
think it's good for america i think it's
good for our culture i think it's good
for the individual that's doing it so
the fact that dakota has that burning in
his belly is a wonderful thing and it's
going to take him a lot of good places
too
but uh you don't know what you don't
know when you're starting and it'll kill
you
i've had a lot of scars from stupid butt
stuff i did that i should have known
yeah and i didn't know over these years
and so
um entree leadership i mean that's your
book 20 25 30 years now in the trenches
of building this thing from a card table
and so this is a great book for anyone
who wants to step into that or thinks
they want to step into that read this
book and if you go oh this doesn't sound
like me at all then you know well i
think i think you can you can again
most entrepreneurs have to
do some things in the business that they
didn't know how to do before and that
they don't necessarily enjoy it's part
of starting and running a business i
there's things i do every day today
after 30 years that i not every day but
every week i get to do something that is
not necessarily my favorite thing in the
world it's part of being the owner you
know it's part of carrying the
responsibility um
but and some of it is things i don't
know how to do i mean we're in this
digital world and i'm i'm a doofus on
some of these things and i'm you know i
can't spell app and so you know it's
just like so you hire the right people
you delegate and i have to go in these
rooms with these young people that work
for me that are smarter than me and i
don't know what they're talking about as
intimidating as crud you know
that's part of the process you gotta you
gotta continue be a continual learner
and keep putting tools in your belt
you're always gonna be doing something
that's uncomfortable but when it's all
the whole business process is
uncomfortable that's a not a good recipe
yeah it's gonna be when you deal with
debt it becomes even worse oh it's going
to bring this beautiful real pain then
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today john 6 35 then jesus
declared i am the bread of life whoever
comes to me will never go hungry and
whoever believes in me will never be
thirsty
our friend les brown said wanting
something is not enough you must hunger
for it
your motivation
must be absolutely compelling
in order to overcome the obstacles
that will invariably come your way
and if you haven't ever listened to les
brown he would say hungry yeah i want to
go watch that youtube video right now
you must be hungry get me fired up and
he gets man just just in one sentence
can just make you just run around the
block like rocky i mean hungry
that is a gift les is a wonderful friend
and a wonderful man oh what one of the
best motivators on the planet just fun
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five landon's with us
in boston hey landon welcome to the
ramsey show
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve how can i help
so um back in july i had some car issues
and um i started hearing a clunking
noise
and so i went to four different
mechanics um they all told me the same
thing that i needed my struts and sway
bar links changed
um
so then the first mechanic i went to the
cheapest mechanic
um they fixed they tried to fix it
and i had to go back there eight
different times for them to either redo
the alignment or they kept on messing up
everything when they're installing
stuff um so fast forward seven months
later i'm still having that issue or i
was having that issue and i went to a
different mechanic
and when he looked at the car to see
what the work that the mechanic did
he said the parts were installed
completely wrong the alignment was way
off and
um my question is
and since now that i have a lot of um i
have the evidence now so he took
pictures as well he gave me a statement
of what they did wrong
so do you think i should go to a small
claims court to try to get my money back
from the first mechanic
how much was it
um in total for it was 9.79
979 dollars
yes okay
um did you go back and talk to the first
mechanic and say hey here's the pictures
this stuff was installed wrong
i need i need a refund um
not yet but when i tried to talk to them
in the beginning to try to get a refund
and go to a different mechanic
they basically just told me to get lost
and that they're not going to fix it
um so that's why i'm trying to see if i
should just take them to court because
they don't want to deal with it and they
want to give me the refund or anything
well here's the thing you're under the
illusion that going to court is easier
than dealing with the people and it's
not
okay
i'm not sure you're going to get
anywhere
either way
because here's the thing let's just
pretend you go to court okay and
you walk in there and judge judy drops
your gavel and says um
you get a 979 dollar judgment against an
incompetent mechanic
mechanic doesn't even show up
he just automatically loses you win the
case
which by the way is probably what will
happen
okay it's not going to be like some
trial that you see on tv where he
actually shows up and you get to argue
about this that's not going to happen
you're not going to get it you're not
going to get any real satisfaction
you're just going to get a judgment for
979
now you've got to go try to execute on
that judgment which means somehow
collect that from this guy who wouldn't
give your refund in the first place so
now you got to go hire a lawyer and take
a lean on his bank account take a lean
on his house
take a lean on whatever
i think you're working really hard for
900 bucks
yes because that's what i was thinking
because um this mechanic it's actually a
franchise so it's like a big company
and so that's why i was thinking like
maybe it'd be worth it to do it
well the franchisor is not liable
the name that's on the name that's on
the front unless it's a company store
you're sure it's a franchise not a
company store
uh i believe it's a franchise it's um
it's actually mavis tire that's what
they're called i don't have any idea
what that means but um no you're not
sure
but um so you probably know it yeah i
mean i'm from the boston area i've
definitely heard of them but i mean like
dave's saying this is a lot of emotional
energy for you to expend
at 979 what do you make of here
um i'm a college student right now so i
only make like 20 grand yeah okay
well uh i think this is going to take up
a lot more of your life than
you anticipate when you enter into this
process is what i'm telling i'm trying
to warn you about that
and you may regret i mean i've been in a
few lawsuits not very many but in every
lawsuit so far that i've ever been in
the winner was the lawyers
and when i got done i never i've never
yet had a sense that justice actually
occurred
i just went through a big old load of
manure
and i got it all over me and that's
really the only i never have never come
out going oh i won
or ooh i lost it was never it was never
this sense of justice
it's kind of it's kind of
defeating in that sense that the court
system can't really ever give you
justice because they don't because by
the time you finish with all the bs that
you go through
even when you win and i've won
everyone i've ever been in i've never
been in one i didn't win
but you don't win yeah after you write
all those checks and you deal with all
this stuff you didn't really win you
just won
but it's just ugh
you know it's not it's not pleasant and
that's why these companies settle these
things
instead of
instead of fighting on principle it's
just because nobody really wins but the
lawyers so
i i
i wouldn't what i would do is i would go
hassle them
i'd go show up over there and talk to
the manager and say listen
i'm not going away that easy
you guys did this wrong you screwed this
up
now you need to do the right thing
because otherwise i'm going to tell a
whole bunch of people that you're crooks
and you're incompetent
and i'm going to go to the franchisor
i'm going to the home office i'm i'm
going to give you about 9 000 worth of
hassle
just because i'm going to make a hobby
out of you
for 900 bucks so you all need to give me
some kind of a refund for the work that
you did
uh because it's it's cost me i'm a broke
college kid and you're screwing me here
now maybe you meant to maybe you didn't
but that's the net result and you need
to do the right thing and if you don't
i'm going to wear social media out
i'm going to wear out your your home
office
and you're going to just wish you'd
never met me
now that you could probably do with less
energy than going to small claims court
but you've got the idea in your head and
you're wrong
that going to small claims court's going
to just make this all whoop then they're
just going to write you a check and
they're not it's not going to be it's
going to be it's going to be
less hassle than being coming a hassle
i'm going to become the squeaky wheel
and i'm gonna go full liam neeson and
i'm gonna make them regret ever screwing
me over and i'm gonna leave a review on
yelp and google reviews i'm gonna report
you to the bbb you're gonna get it from
all angles who is this guy he's
destroying us yeah uh but again you're
expending a lot of energy and if you
want to do it for fun that's fine but
this may just be one of those things you
go never again life goes on life goes on
yeah i know one place i'm not taking a
car and anytime anybody brings it up i'm
gonna tell them not to go there i mean
they could be just that simple stand
outside with a sign going don't go here
there you go
it's whatever protest you want to do
yeah or take it to judge judy that could
be fun too get yourself on tv
or not yeah
those are those shows are entertaining
if nothing else good people yeah the
problem with them is is that people get
the sense that that really happens
the sensationalizing of it yeah judge
judy's no more of a judge than dr laura
is a doctor i mean
come on um
it's
and laura's a friend of mine by the way
but she's a person a doctor she's not
got a phd it's just a nickname
and so
dr john deloney is a real doctor he
actually has two phds not a medical
doctor don't ask him for medical advice
although he'll give it to you yeah it's
um he'll google it um
but yeah but yeah so that's the problem
with that is it's just
there's sometimes you have to use the
courts i mean we have to use them in
real estate for evictions and things and
it's those are usually fairly clean
that's a fairly dialed in process
but you know collecting on a debt i've
just never collected on a debt now could
he get a lawyer to write a letter to
where he kind of spooks them a little
bit and they you know won't be fun that
could you're gonna write a check to do
that yeah maybe a smaller one but yeah
good work
good luck small claims court you can
file yourself and go in there and be
your own lawyer
which we know what that is dangerous
good hour george well done thank you job
booth people you both folk did a great
work did a great work the booth
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600-plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermzyshow.com
[Music]
you